bondir pin nord-ouest de kiev quatrième
jour d'offensive russe sur cet axe
stratégique
nous faisons route vers le centre ville
yvelines est un district clé pour
l'encerclement de la capitale côté
ukrainien la résistance s'organise
allez on va flinguer des [__] de rue
ça quel côté tu as tué des russes tous
les jours le deuil
à combien
ça fait quatorze jours que je suis là
mais il habite ici je suis d'ici
maintenant attention à nier des sandales
pas jusque dans la rue là
regardez bien morne
checkpoint ici c'est chaud c'est très
dangereux vide
là ce sont 200 m
aussi quand tu vois les tanks
attends un peu
c'est pas une bonne idée il faut y aller
voici la ligne de front dire pin en
plein coeur de cette ville de 60 mille
habitants c'est là que sont positionnés
1500 combattants volontaires comme artem
et des forces spéciales l'ukrainienne
des civils continuent de s'échapper le
quartier général de la résistance se
trouve dans les caves de cet immeuble en
plein centre ville
nous ne sommes pas caché pour nous il
n'y a pas de retour possible
c'est notre pays
tous ces soldes envahisseurs ou s'ils
vont regretter d'être venu on va faire
de l'engrais avec leurs cadavres
avec leur présence dans cette ville des
faubourgs de kiev transformée en zone de
guerre
les tanks russes sont désormais à 15 km
de la capitale